so bring me back to the beginning Iran
born
Christian
Assyrian and Armenian Assyrian and
Armenian okay
very briefly what is a Syrian Assyrian
is Babylonian they're the first
Christians first warriors
uh you know them and Armenians always
debate on who was the first Christian if
you read the Bible you see Assyrians all
the time Aramaic so I speak Aramaic so
Passion of the Christ you speak Arabic I
speak Arabia the movie passing the
crisis we understand what they were
saying wow nobody else well I mean
except for seven of us
wait you grew up
language the Buzz rent yes
yes is it different in Aramaic than it
is in English
the Syrian yeah it's close time
yes they got to make it about themselves
every single time we were having a nice
moment over here with the Christians the
Jews come in and anyway uh okay so so
you're in Iran
what is happening in Iran during the the
reign of the Shah
so the Shah goes from being this 21 year
old guy comes in his father is this
powerful man who is kicked out a couple
times he is feared he is hated he is you
know respected he's a guy that raises a
son in a way that they're not that close
it's like you know it's the father it's
the shot the king and the son has to go
do all this different work he spoke
seven different languages Asha she smart
guy he could do interviews in literally
seven different languages he comes in he
changes the game
was a guy that a lot of the he would be
the modern day Bernie Sanders so they
wanted mosader to be the president he
was going to give the oil money back to
the people all this stuff and then with
the help of CIA you'll read this in many
different places the Shah ends up coming
in uh he becomes the king and it changes
everything in Iran you know education
improves women Freedom voice they can
become lawyers you know there was a
entertainment aspect to it Frank Sinatra
all these guys used to go to Iran it was
top three richest like the wealthiest of
the wealthiest in the 70s in the late
60s you would go to Iran Burma and Cuba
was it like Dubai I'm trying to imagine
it was like Dubai I mean listen uh
Elizabeth Taylor was dating the
Ambassador zahidi they were together so
she would go to visit them Elizabeth and
she dated everybody but she was also
dating at the time and then all of a
sudden you know Khomeini from France is
sending these tapes before there was
YouTube there were these tapes that
would go viral so guys were sitting
there recording these tapes and giving
it away to people and how many is
talking about how bad it is what's going
on in Iran and how he put this party
together the 2500 Year party in Iran and
that was the end of it I cannot believe
you spend this much money look how much
money you're spending on the lavish
party he invited everybody to Iran if
you ever see the pictures of this party
it's insane what he did with the party
and then eventually you know Jimmy
Carter comes in
December 31st 1977 there's a toast Jimmy
Carter says this is a very important
partner to us the moment he imagine New
Year's you can be anywhere in the world
he's in Iran okay
he leaves
next thing you know gradually Revolution
starts one by one by one and then
eventually nine million people revolted
after this event that took place uh
Cinema wrecks fire in a city called is
like a bunch of provinces it's a it was
a beautiful place this movie theater 400
people are in there they lock the doors
from both ends they turn the place on
fire people die the police station is
right across the street Khomeini says it
was uh Shaw's people that did a savak
Slovak is like the CIA MI6
and Rashad says we didn't do anything
here why would we kill 400 people well
many shots people like how many people
did this anyways the people believe
khomeini's camp and they said Shaw was
behind this
long story short I'm born October 1878
which is at the peak of Cinema RX fire
my mother when they're you know we're
going to the hospital curfew 10 o'clock
they had to be escorted I go to the
hospital I'm born uh three months later
Shaw's out
and then Iran Falls and the rest is
history what happens to Christians in
Iran at this time it's a scary time to
be a Christian it's a scary time to be
Baha'i it is a scary time to be pro-shaw
it is a scary time to be uh any military
leader part of shots Camp they were you
know that was connected to the Shah no
he was a fan of the Shah my dad was a
regular guy we don't come from a a lot
of money uh but my dad they were
imperialist and my mother they were
Communists my mother's family they were
strong Communists and at the time
and so they couldn't stand the Shah you
know she they were happy the shaw fell
so I'm in the middle of my mom he thinks
rich people are greedy my dad thinks
poor people are lazy and I'm seeing this
is the big going back it's the best
debate ever
welcome to America
my mother taught me the paranoia site
you know and I think you need that in
business I think you need that in life I
think you need that what do you mean by
that the parent paranoia where you got
it you know only the paranoid survive
Andy Grove the Hungarian entrepreneur
who ran Intel he's the Godfather of
Silicon Valley where everybody admired
this guy he wrote a book in the 80s and
maybe the early 90s called only the
paranoid survive in the game of business
if you're not paranoid boom somebody
takes you out same in the military
same in business you need a little bit
of that so growing up in this kind of a
climate in Iran you're always like are
you Christian why do you ask instead of
yes I am you know hey what nationality
are you instead of giving the answers
like what's the motive behind the
question because you're a little bit
paranoid so
that kind of helps I know people may
look at it and say was that really a
good thing or a bad thing I think it's a
very good thing okay so then from Iran
yeah you guys flee yes go to Germany yes
refugee camp yep are you worried about
going to like a camp in Germany given
the history yeah let me put it to you
this way man I mean for us in Iran
Khomeini died this is like he died June
2nd I want to save 89 uh June 2nd or 3rd
he dies I'm in school parents can't find
me you know there is no Uber tax this
that riots protesting everywhere I'm
trying to find my mom I'm 10 years old
and we finally do they take us home we
get to the house my mom and dad have
this exchange together we got to get the
hell out of here we're not staying here
if he stays here he's got to serve the
military here boom six weeks later we go
to Germany refugee camp we're on the
plane Lufthansa
and you hear the announcer saying you
know uh you're free to drink alcohol
we've officially crossed the border
everybody felt free because nobody
thought it was real until they said you
can drink alcohol it's a very wild
moment yeah I will never forget that
foreign